[Music]
[Applause]
he's the best selling author of the book
playmakers you can still pick that up
and i think mike is going to be on the
road maybe signing books columbus or
pittsburgh or west virginia
who knows he's gonna he'll travel to
your home that's how accommodating mike
florio is pro football talk live co-host
mike let me start with the tom brady
news if you would have said tom was
going to be the lead guy for fox as
their football analyst no matter when it
is
i would have said no way uh
what was your reaction
yeah i was stunned dan and first of all
i hope you're you're feeling well and i
admire the fact that you're powering
through it that's great to see but again
get well soon and uh and good to talk to
you as always i was stunned because it
didn't seem like the kind of thing tom
brady was ever going to do
but maybe he realized number one the
money is really really really good
you can still do a lot of other things
with your life when you are calling
games as opposed to preparing to play in
games
18
weeks of the regular season and then
beyond and i'd love to know what kind of
an offer they made i assume they made
him an offer he can't refuse and we
haven't seen the number yet the over
under for me is 29.5 million and i won't
be surprised if it's over
really i i just think it's going to take
something like that to get him to commit
he's the white whale he and peyton
manning are the two white whales and
peyton manning's kind of doing a
piecemeal with espn where he's kind of
in it but he's not really in it to get
brady to go all in i suspect they had to
drop a lot of money on the table wow
that's just a guess it's just a guess
i'll bet peyton manning wants to know
what tom's getting paid
but i thought tom would want to lean
towards ownership
business
running a team
well and i think he can do both i think
that he will continue to amass his
fortune and this is a great platform for
him
to do it i remember at one point steve
young
was the subject of a profile in a
magazine the name of which i can't
remember but
steve young said that he was in a hedge
fund and still is i believe out in
california and his partners wanted him
to be involved with espn and the nfl
because it made
his other interests more marketable it
gave him something to talk about they
wanted that and i think that brady can
leverage the platform the visibility
into these various other business
pursuits that he has so he's still part
of the game even if he's not playing and
when you look at the total time
commitment and what you're going to make
doing it and how it can help these other
things you're trying to do as he works
toward having enough money to become an
owner it won't surprise me and i don't
think it takes off the table the
possibility of becoming a minority owner
of the miami dolphins what is fox going
to say no they're not saying no to him
continuing with the buccaneers while
he's technically employed by fox moving
forward so i i i take nothing off the
table i just think this expands
opportunities not limits them for brady
tom brady will be the lead analyst for
fox for the 2023 season
2024 season or other
i'll say 24.
if i had to pick one right now that's
the next super bowl they have after this
year they've got two of the next three
so he would debut in a super bowl year
it gives him one more year with the
bucks
and one more year with
whoever he may choose to try to play for
in 2023 look and and i know that
buccaneers fans don't want to hear it
but it's not going to stop me from
saying it the miami stuff was real he
was going to become a minority owner of
the team they were going to pursue sean
payton they did pursue sean payton they
admitted they made the phone call it was
going to be a lot more than a phone call
but for the brian flores lawsuit that
put the kibosh on everything otherwise
it's quite possible we would be talking
right now about brady and payton as the
quarterback and coach of the dolphins i
don't think that goes away automatically
for next year a lot of depends on what
the dolphins do this year what tua does
other factors come into play but i think
the possibility of him playing somewhere
else next year is still on the table
just because he's got this deal with fox
it's when he retires not next year and i
would say 24 if i had to guess right now
he's mike florio from pro football talk
live make sure you pick up a copy of his
great book playmakers
i think you're on record as saying that
the cleveland browns should cut ties
with baker mayfield
let me give you my thought on that and
then you can give me your side of this
because if i'm looking at this if i'm
the cleveland browns i have to look at
the season coming up and say we got
deshaun watson we don't know when we
have him
we have an insurance policy
and granted he's expensive but let's say
desean watson misses eight games
if i have baker mayfield to play those
games to audition for another team and
he's healthy maybe i can get more from
him and i can salvage this season as
opposed to having a backup quarterback
in there and baker mayfield is playing
someplace else your turn
i think that makes a ton of sense in
theory
but the problem is
as a practical matter the damage to the
relationship
has become so severe and i think last
week's article from espn jake trotter
a bunch of different things we didn't
already know
and i know that it's frowned upon to
guess on whose sources may be
this all goes back to mayfield and his
camp
i think this is his way
of rattling the cage to get out of
cleveland and the one thing to me
that i think is unmendable
if mayfield and or people close to him
believe that they specifically set him
up to fail week 17 at pittsburgh monday
night football prime time to make it
easier
to move on from him to deshaun watson
that is something there's no coming back
from so dan
your your
strategy i like that a lot more than
we're just gonna squat on this guy's
contract until a trade opportunity falls
out of the sky at least there is some
short-term beneficial goal we may need
maybe for the whole season i don't know
we don't know what the league's gonna do
yeah the trevor bauer suspension for two
years that's got to be a factor in how
the league looks at what they're going
to do with deshawn watson maybe he gets
out for the whole year you need baker
mayfield well they better be working
hard behind the scenes to put some lips
on the rear end of baker mayfield to get
him on board with that because right now
he's not on board with it that's the
problem and once you make the move for
deshaun watson your relationship with
baker mayfield ends if you prolong it
you're only creating another distraction
for a team that doesn't need got 22
distractions with deshaun watson you
don't need a 23rd with baker mayfield
explain to me how this topic came up of
maybe another nfl team in the dallas
area
the mayor of dallas started tweeting
about it now the mayor of dallas wants a
separate stadium
in south dallas where an afc team would
be located well that's just stupid the
idea of trying to build another stadium
when you already have one and that's how
you get jerry jones on board after i let
it
marinate for a little bit yesterday i
thought you know
yeah jerry jones doesn't want another
team in his market
but he probably wouldn't mind another
team in his stadium
20 nfl games per year and you're the
landlord you're staying cronky you got
all your own team's games plus all the
games of the b team and if jerry jones
is worried about some other team in
dallas come on he can make a ton of
money off of this and i think it makes
sense dan
as the nfl tries to increase inventory
they're not going to go any more than 18
games i think eventually we're going to
see 18. the only way you increase
inventory beyond that
increase the number of teams and the
easiest places to put expansion teams
are in the markets that are big enough
for two teams and that already have a
stadium dallas chicago are the two that
i would watch
and whether jerry jones likes it or not
i mean think of the money he could make
from having that second team and i think
that goes a long way toward getting
getting him to agree to it at the
appropriate time if we ever get there
yeah i i understand the logic to that
and i agree if i'm jerry jones i just do
what stan kroenke did in los angeles and
say i'm going to build this build this
masterpiece and you come in here and you
pay help pay for this masterpiece
clippers were doing that with the you
know with the lakers in los angeles we
see that you could see chicago maybe
doing that reaching out and saying but
does the nfl want
two teams
in those markets or would they rather
expand to
other places where they they don't have
a foothold yet
makes more sense to take advantage of
state-of-the-art stadiums that you
already have and they're talking about
building a venue in chicago outside of
town one of the ways you pay for that is
having two teams play there instead of
one dan i remember before the nfl went
back to la al michaels said if the nfl
goes back it's going back with two teams
and he was right yeah london is a market
we have to continue to watch they have
two nfl ready stadiums there wembley and
tottenham hotspur they use them every
year for the smattering of games
if the nfl ever puts one team in london
i think the nfl is putting two teams in
london and this is a long term play but
i can see 32 becoming 34 becoming 36
becoming 38 i think the hard cap is 40.
the quarterback play is going to be an
issue and every time we think there's
more than enough good quarterbacks to go
around we find out like this year that
there isn't but but i think that the
gambling
legalization as that spreads
as the money keeps getting bigger and
bigger
we're going to see the talk i think in
the next five years the talk of
expanding the league is really going to
take root
yeah um
and i agree with you i i understand the
logic behind that uh i i'd be remiss if
and wouldn't be a journalist if i didn't
bring up the desean watson situation
where this trial
might not be heard until after this next
season is that is that a fair time frame
for this or do you see something that's
a little more expedited
absolutely i believe these cases go to
trial after the upcoming season okay and
you've got 22 of them and dan they're
not going to be tried all at once with
22 plaintiffs going on the witness stand
and saying what deshaun watson did
according to their allegations
if you're if you're desean watson you
want to isolate these you want to do
these one at a time well good luck
getting 22 cases done
in one off season
good luck with that i mean this may not
be done until 24.
unless he settles and i'm on record as
saying from the day the browns traded
for him he should have settled the cases
do it for the browns do it for the fans
the fans got enough to worry about then
when these cases are going to get
resolved
what the blowback's going to be is he
going to be suspended now is he going to
be suspended later are they going to
suspend him now and then maybe leave the
door open to suspend him later based
upon the outcomes of these lawsuits this
is just a distraction that you shouldn't
want as a team or as a fan base no
matter how good the player is i the one
thing you can say a lot about steven
rossi under the dolphins but he had it
right last year he wasn't trading for
watson unless all 22 cases were settled
18 were ready to settle watson decided
not to do it
i think he would admit now he probably
should have knocked out the 18 while he
could and focus on the remaining four
is this the first time we've spoken to
you since paulie lost his bet that uh he
thought that we'd have a quarterback
taken in the first 13 picks
no yeah i didn't know that there was
such a bet was there a pie in the face
yeah
and then uh you also
you're losing your bet with tom brady
right i've just yeah yeah well seton
intervened
with the arbitrator's decision that
it's not over until week one okay you
think there's a chance tom brady still
is the
quarterback no i'm just buying i i was
given the opportunity to remember i
could pick the pie
if i go ahead and accept the medicine
now but if it's week one it's got to be
lemon meringue which apparently is the
equivalent of putting your face into a
vat of boiling yes yes
yes paulie all right i'll throw out a
new bet for the room this week one
starter for the 49ers at quarterback is
jimmy garoppolo
oh
i wouldn't rule that out would you roll
it in yeah hell yes
it seems like there's a wild card we
don't know what they think of trey lance
that's the one thing we don't know
and that's why i think there's a chance
it will be around oh yeah i i wouldn't
be surprised if he's the starter right
they just want you know there's no
market for garoppolo i think they
overplayed their hand i think they were
getting they were asking for two second
round picks instead of just saying
see it jimmy uh well he went and got
shoulder surgery without telling him
john lynch recently said that that
pulled the plug abruptly on any trade
talks when garoppolo goes off campus to
get shoulder surgery but garoppolo in
his own way is making it known he
doesn't want to be there and the worst
case scenario for him is to get to a
week before the start of the season and
they say you're going to make 25 million
this year it becomes fully guaranteed as
of week one trade lance is our starter
you either take 10 million dollars or
we're going to cut you in good luck
finding a job a week before the start of
the season
any story lines to keep an eye on here
for the audience
i mean the baker mayfield and jimmy
garoppolo stuff is really top of the
stack keep an eye on what happens moving
forward because
there's just so much drama baked into it
what's seattle going to do at
quarterback and
do you think geno smith is going to be i
was just going to say that geno smith
right now is the number one guy on the
depth chart in seattle
and
dan i think in a weird sort of way
and i think the seahawks are going to be
better this year than we expect i think
pete carroll is pissed and i think he's
determined to make this team into a
winner without russell wilson and geno
smith played pretty well last year when
he got thrust into search remember they
were chanting his name on the thursday
night game against the rams he lost by
three to the steelers lost by three to
the saints beat the jaguars blew them
out he was 20 or 24 and then all of a
sudden russell wilson's good to go again
after geno smith goes 20 for 24. i think
pete carroll is is enamored with the
idea
of showing the world run game defense
and geno smith is good enough to win
man
if i'm going to get back at russell
wilson i think i will have a little
better ammo than gino smith
just said welcome back to team it's one
hey thursday night the schedule comes
out one of those games is denver at
seattle that is going to be a hell of a
night when that happens i'm predicting
week four maybe sunday night football we
see denver at seattle just like tommy
going back to new england last year that
will be a hell of a night and
our christmas lineup is that already uh
set the game or wasn't that leaked
the the well it wasn't leaked what
they're doing is they're announcing
every day one of the networks is
announcing one of their games today cbs
announced that they've got broncos rams
in that 4 30 p.m eastern slot on
christmas it'll be three games on
christmas day
fox at one then cbs and then an nbc game
that night but dan i got an idea for the
nfl i haven't written this yet i talked
about this earlier
instead of dropping all 18 weeks on
thursday night and with these little
piecemeal here's a game here he's here's
a game there why not take over the whole
week
and do the first four weeks of the
season monday the next four weeks
tuesday the next four weeks wednesday
and then the final six weeks thursday
instead of dropping it all at once
really piss off baseball basketball and
hockey and commandeer the whole week
what if you did 18 days
with 18 weeks you could i i could sign
on for that i think it'll look at a
certain point it gets a little old i say
take a week just take a week monday
tuesday wednesday thursday and i bet
it's moving in that direction you see
their understanding there's benefit in
in
a game here a game there
instead of all 272 getting announced at
once yeah i think it gets watered down
where you're going wait week what and
you're trying to you know keep an eye on
what's going on and a lot of times when
we look at the schedule release it's how
many road games in a row how do we end
our season toughest games are going to
be
bye week after the bye week you know the
strategy behind that it's not just you
know here's the schedule it's oh my gosh
we got back-to-back conference games or
we go west coast then back east then we
go west coast again those are the the
tricky elements that i always keep an
eye on mike it's always great to talk to
you good luck with the book i know it's
doing well it's playmakers it's
available wherever books are sold and
thanks for joining us thanks dan thanks
for having me pal that's mike florio